hi I'm Maria today I'm going to take
popular food and make it fancy I've
always wanted to do that
I host this year by myself but I have an
amazing co-host today
thank you so much for having me I am
very excited to be here and doing that
is now crossed off my bucket list oh my
God thank you so much for saying that
all right let's see what we are making
fancy today
cam belts cream of mushroom soup my
first thought is I have no thoughts on
how you would make this messy like what
you are born in Vietnam yeah you moved
to United States when you were eight yes
have you had this before I have had many
canned foods in my life and I have never
had this same I've never had this before
I think we should try let's try it this
is a thick cheers
[Music]
salty yeah like hint of mushroom yeah do
you have any idea of what we could
possibly do with this yeah I think I
should maybe I like how you're playing
with it
star maybe great idea comes out I want
to make it something very unexpected
honestly I feel like you've been doing
this for way too long and the ideas are
just like coming to you like it's
nothing close your eyes really quick
I have something for you
and open your eyes what's this I want
you to randomly select one of these cans
to add to this recipe
dark sweet cherries this doesn't belong
together you know that it's kind of help
I wanted to do something unexpected and
a cherry and a mushroom they are very
unexpected we're excited to make it
fancy all right here's what I got
cherries chocolate heavy cream coffee
cocoa powder and buttermilk from the
palm tree we got baking powder sugar
baking soda powdered sugar homemade
almond extra cake flour vanilla extract
cornstarch and cherry liquor
all right let's get started
make it fancy first and foremost our
star cream of mushroom cream of mushroom
how do you open with that long nail oh
it sucks very much easier so I'm going
to strain so I want to make mushroom and
cream separate I'm just going along with
you I really don't know where we're
taking this I want to dehydrate mushroom
you don't want to push too hard but you
kind of want to take the mushroom out
from this soup yeah
so mushrooms are separated so I'm going
to put Mushroom on parchment paper and
you can new spread just one layer we are
going to dehydrate until crispy
so it took three hours to make this
crispy so we're gonna put this in a
grinder turns out we dehydrated but
there are not many mushrooms yeah so
it's just cream I still have no idea
what we're doing but we're here hold
your ears
[Music]
I'm gonna bring something else
oh wow I'm so glad you are here can you
dump do you want to taste it yeah
cheers
that's salty like kind of has Umami too
like a finishing sauce you know before
we eat everything let's get fancy
[Music]
good
so now we're gonna make powder batter
and what this batter is going to be for
I'm going to add sugar so we're making
something sweet maybe in a cocoa powder
oh it smells good nice baking powder and
baking soda I'm gonna put salt on the
side and we are going to put all the wet
ingredients one ball buttermilk and oil
and I'm going to add two teaspoon of
vanilla a teaspoon oh I did not know
that two eggs and the separated cream
the star of the show
yeah
you think so no
no
okay can you put wet ingredients to dry
ingredients yes and we're gonna put our
coffee it's not the Vietnamese coffee
but it'll do
[Applause]
it
oh it really does smell really good
let's change it to spatula it's like hot
cocoa so this looks good we're gonna go
on Next Step well it's definitely cake
you never know all right let's put
butter and like I just want to mention
the smell yeah it does not smell like
cake yeah it's like a mushroom the
mushroom is really coming through we
want to make it evenly I usually use
sour cream or yogurt when I bake cake
but mushroom doesn't have a lot of fat
so it was very difficult to tweak around
how much moisture Contents I should
reduce from the other ingredients right
let's put this in an oven okay let's
yeah I was wondering when these were
gonna come in and we are going to bring
it to a boil oh yes chocolate cake with
cherries all right so I have a musher so
are we making like a syrup or something
so we are making simple soup and the
cherry jam oh and we got a string nice
the Cherry bucking to the pot I am
getting one tablespoon of cherry syrup
one tablespoon of cornstarch so this is
like a cherry slurry yeah it's gonna
make it thick big now I'm going to use
half cup syrup two tablespoons of cherry
liquor I like to use alcohol because
they kind of musk some sort of like
weird smell so this case is mushroom so
this is homemade almond extract okay it
took three months special so why almond
extract and not vanilla extract almond
extract kind of compliments with cherry
and this is made with cherry pie so it's
kind of nice go together looks great
time for Next Step let's do it all right
can you put heavy cream in a pot and we
want to make sure not boil now we wait
now we wait so you moved when you are
eight how did you learn English from
watching SpongeBob
it was SpongeBob and then Anthony
Bourdain
so you want to cover hot heavy cream and
kind of want to count 30 seconds you can
also use plastic so it kind of Trapped
heat oh I'm learning all the tips and
tricks I love this let's come wait you
count in Japanese and I can count in
Vietnamese each knee Sun she go look
nana
we love myself
Japanese just sounds so cool it sounds
so cool too so we shouldn't forget Main
Ingredients mushroom powder yes can we
taste it
ah that was good stuff I think it kind
of adds Umami you're a genius okay
what's next we will see
that's a lot of cream so I'm guessing
we're making whipped cream right we'll
see
when I make whipped cream I usually use
whisk I don't like using um you just
want to make your life harder yeah but
this is too much long liter I still
think you should use the Whisk do you
want to do it no so we're gonna put
powdered sugar and we're gonna put
cornstarch oh why cornstarch Purdy
stabilites the whipped cream and do you
want to put vanilla I think something is
not right if I'm using this so let's use
risk let's make our life harder you know
what here you go you you can do that
it's a good workout so how you feeling I
think you're right okay girl move over
my soul kind of breaks a little bites
again it's okay
nice and let's decorate the thing the
cake right so cake is baked and it's
cool so it's cake hot pink the thing is
that big kind of cold and we are going
to dub okay
this is the Cherry simple soup we made
with the Cherry liqueur we have to use
this all so it's gonna be drenched you
guys cannot smell but we smell mushroom
for sure once you finish you can flip
and we do other side
you know what Campbell's Cream of
mushrooms nickname is salty soup
mushroom of the sea
oh
we're gonna do surgery cake surgery can
you put this cake upside down onto this
base and this is a cream we made earlier
and then we're gonna put Jam so we pipe
cream in a border so this Cherry drama
doesn't bleed out second layer I really
cannot wait to taste this cake me too
this is the ganache with dehydrated
mushrooms so we're gonna decorate on top
nice
then we're gonna put fresh cherries on
top that is so pretty yay we have
chocolate curls
we are done
[Music]
cream of mushroom black forest cake very
fancy this is super fancy I can't
believe we made this we made too much so
I think we have to have our mutual
friends do you think he would be able to
guess what's in here I don't think so I
don't think so either
so we have very very special guest HBO
are you wearing
a popular country
this is what we made
it looks fantastic thank you
can you guess what popular item is in
this is it like the Hostess chocolate
cake thing ER it's Savory we'll give you
a hint this popular item it's called
America's Bechamel
[Music]
I'll keep eating it but it's good right
one more hit it's canned one more hat
it's a soup oh is it cream of mushroom
yeah
one more secret ingredient but it's
actually sweet and if you look at the
cake you can tell on what it is the
cherries yes
one last things to do three two one make
it fancy
foreign
[Music]